anyone and I mean anyone can take a
plain white box and turn it into an
architectural Masterpiece the best part
is it takes less than 60 seconds to
create endless designs but you see
there's a problem oh actually there's a
few problems but before we get into
those let me explain what the hell is
going on here this is graphisoft's
official AI plug-in for archicad 27 on
both Mac and PC it uses the power of
stable diffusion XL to create AI powered
images all you have to do is type in a
few words and within seconds you have
inspiration but like I said there's a
problem and installation is one of them
let's dive in so I can show you exactly
how to install this plugin finally I'll
teach you everything you need to know to
make great AI powered architecture let's
go to start using archicad's AI
visualizer first of all you need to
download and install this plugin like I
mentioned it is an incredibly
challenging and painful procedure but
we're going to get there together today
first things first you need to come to
this graphisoft AI visualizer online
I'll link it down below so you can go
straight to it you need to come to the
download section and press download of
course Windows and Mac options are
available once you've signed in it's
going to allow you to download it if you
come to the installation instructions on
the right hand side it will also provide
additional installation instructions for
Windows it is ridiculously easy all you
have to do is download the zip and copy
and paste a few folders for Mac on the
other hand unfortunately there is a few
pages that we need to get through
however don't be scared off this is
relatively simple so first things first
let's zoom out a little bit and you'll
need to download this package all you
need to do is press command space and
type in terminal and it will open up
your terminal for you now generally
these instructions are relatively
correct except for the very first
instruction that tells you to copy and
paste this section right here and paste
it into your terminal if you do that
paste it directly into terminal
nothing's going to happen you're going
to sit waiting for hours on end what you
actually need to do is figure out where
this code came from and then copy and
paste it directly from the website again
I will link the actual website where
this code comes from directly in the
description below so to make the Arad AI
visualizer work and install properly
we're basically installing home breu on
our Mac systems and the easiest way to
find that direct code is of course to go
to the home brew website to be able to
install it successfully come to this
website find the direct copy icon for
the main link which appears perfectly
identical to the one on the installation
instructions but just doesn't seem to
work for some reason so make sure you
copy it directly from home brw go to
your terminal paste it in and then after
that you're going to be able to follow
these instructions step by step I won't
bore you with this because it's
relatively easy all it's asking you to
do is press enter type in your
computer's password press enter again
wait a little while it does take a
decent amount of time to download
because obviously it is a relatively
large download itself and then copy and
paste a few files over first it asks you
to copy and paste the SD web UI file
directly into your arcad 27 folder so if
it comes to your applications graphisoft
aryad 27 you just paste it into this
main folder here again it's about 20 gig
so you will need a decent amount of
space to install this after that it will
ask you to drag and drop this run sh
file over from the folder directly into
your terminal window now of course I
don't have my terminal window open but
all we need to do is drag drop and let
it do the rest itself once again it's
going to take a bit of time to install
but once you're done with that entire
procedure it will showcase this code
here in the center mine looks a little
bit something similar to that not
entirely but all we really looking for
is model loaded in x amount of seconds
and you're good to go once you've
installed this script we can jump into
aryad 27 and start using the Arad
visualizer if for whatever reason you
guys are having some serious problems
installing the Arad visualizer jump on
the Discord chat it is the link down
below completely for free and we'll be
able to answer some of these questions
hopefully for you along the way now ai
is a fantastic tool but without clear
Direction you could waste thousands of
hours designing a project and get
absolutely nowhere that's why I've
designed the DIY architectural brief for
architects around the world ensures your
client's projects have a clear direction
from day one that mean means if you're
using AI you can pull key words directly
from the brief to help guide the AI
itself over my career I've witnessed the
transformative power of a well-crafted
brief it's the compass that guides your
project the blueprint of your client's
Vision without it you're sailing blind
into a sea of escalating costs and
directionless design please don't leave
your career to chance swing by my
website linked down below and secure
your DIY architecture brief today once
it's all installed we can then jump into
Arad 27 now it doesn't pop up like a
regular plugin it doesn't have any
toolbars it doesn't have any Windows you
need to come up to window pettes and
make sure AI visualizer appears in your
actual palette to know that you've
installed it properly the AI visualizer
works best of course in a 3D window so
if we were to Simply create a mesh tool
let's come to our side create a big box
and then create a large Square in the
middle let's go 50 m by 6 M just a very
simple plain box let's make it 4 M tall
let's paint it white press okay and
let's go into 3D so right now we have a
very very plain very boring box and we
might just be stuck for inspiration we
might not know what the hell we're going
to do but we know we want it to be a
nice beautiful long house we want to set
up our actual articad visualization and
seene however we want that final result
to look so if we're doing an external
shot front on if we're doing side on we
want to leave leave the actual camera
angle exactly like we want to showcase
it in the visualizer so let's start
maybe with a human perspective somewhere
from one side it also works perfectly
with Interiors as well after that we'll
go back to our window our pallet and
open up our visualizer let's just keep
the exact same prompt again AI is really
bad at replicating the same thing over
and over again so it doesn't matter how
many times you press generate it'll
always through something new for the
purpose of this I'm happy with a very
very basic prompt we can change it as we
dive deeper into this video the shape
Fidelity basically understands how
closely you want to mimic the actual
shape 80% means I'm happy for it to be a
box and you can truncate a little bit
but if I needed to be exactly as per the
shape I'd smash that up to 100 otherwise
if I wasn't fast at all what kind of
shapes it was going to throw at me maybe
I just needed some real inspiration we
could put that to zero as well in this
instance let's leave it at 80% just so
we can create something relatively
similar like you saw at the start of the
video image size will depend on how long
this actually takes to render out and
gener generate so the larger you make
this image the longer it's going to take
purpose of this I'm happy with a smaller
image size the iterations basically is
going to define the exact Precision of
the AI generated model so if you want a
really really intricate perfectly
detailed model bring that up to 45 maybe
even all the way to 50 and it will take
a little bit longer to do it but it will
produce a much better result so let's
leave it at 45 seconds see how long this
takes and we can then move on to prompt
strength prompt strength is utilizing
the actual information we've provided to
the AI as the basis of what it's going
to create so if I put modern residential
home glass concrete tropical Landscaping
it's going to try find all of those
things at about 75% accuracy which means
it might throw some timber in there it
might throw some different materials
that I haven't actually specified at 75%
but it will predominantly use those if I
drag that all the way down to 25 it will
do whatever it wants it gets pretty wild
when you drop at 25 and relatively
Innovative so if you're really looking
for some inspiration just drop it all
the way to 25 drop your Precision down
to Z 25 as well and then you're going to
be able to turn through this quicker
let's leave that at 75 just to see what
we can actually produce the local engine
we don't have to touch any of this start
high vram mode as well it's going to
take a little bit more power so
hopefully you have the capacity to turn
this on if you don't you can obviously
leave it off first we need to start the
actual AI engine now if you hit generate
first it will change the screen and tell
you that there's an error so you need to
hit start AI engine first this does take
about 60 seconds every time and we'll
start a new terminal window if you press
the close button it will show you the
terminal window automatically and once
it is finished running through that code
you're going to be able to click back on
aryad and then finally you're going to
be able to press the beautiful generate
button so we've pressed that generate
button it basically just says generating
image for a good 45 seconds up to 5
minutes depending on the settings the
Precision that you actually set up these
settings to so if you want it to go
quicker again just slide these sliders
down as much as you can but otherwise
I'll see you guys back in about a minute
well this time it has generated an
incredibly different image to what we've
actually provided and what we've said to
do and it's predominantly based on the
slider settings we've Ed so this image
here I don't love it I think it's it's
nice it's okay it's exceptionally well
rendered out from a box but it's not at
all what we're looking for so maybe
let's drop our iterations back down to
25 and press the generate button again
let's see what it can come up with a
second time around this time it's come
up with something a little bit more
alike to the actual rectangle box that
we've provided it as a starting base and
it isn't bad it's done a relatively
decent job at creating a very basic
glass concrete Rend up if we wanted to
save that image we could simply hit the
save button save it anywhere we like on
our desktop and just press save it will
export a very small image because that's
what we set it up to but that is the
finished render as one example now
obviously you'll see that there's a few
issues like right over here there's a
small issue it's very wobbly along this
top roof it isn't nice and straight like
it's supposed to be there's a tree half
growing into our building half growing
out and it's not perfect but when we
look at it relatively quickly it looks
like a half decent image but when we
stare at it for a long period of time we
will notice a lot of faults now let's
say we wanted to make something a little
bit more holiday theme with Christmas
coming out for some people around the
world we might be wanting to turn this
into something different so let's wrap
around the front again let's reopen our
visualizer and let's change our prompt
this time we'll go Ultra Modern
architectural home Timber glass and
concrete facade Christmas lights and
Santa Claus on roof now this could end
horribly wrong for us I have no idea
what it's going to generate but let's
find find out what we might be able to
produce if we're looking for a little
bit more of a holiday themed render that
we might be able to present potentially
on social media or to our clients well
it definitely generated an Ultra Modern
architectural home with Timber glass and
concrete and it's beautiful I quite like
it it's not too bad at all there is no
Christmas lights that I can see in this
image there is no Santa Claus on the
roof unfortunately when we get into
those nly Grinny architectural details
that actually make architectural houses
a home we just don't get them with the
stable diffusion XL plug-in for CAD now
for to try one more additional render
let's say we want to try something
that's been inspired by Jo ad said here
in Australia he's got a beautiful
Cliffhanger home where it's a very
simple two box shape massive can to
lever across and some curves some arches
something slightly different so now we
clearly have two volumes stacked on top
of each other we have this beautiful
caner lever up the top I haven't gone
into too much detail so let's see what
it can actually produce juice if I was
to once again go front on make sure we
see that can L to be able to do that
maybe we even extend the mesh a little
bit further and show some hot spots to
show that it is a cliff there we go now
we have a falling piece of terrain that
we can zoom all the way out in make sure
it's clearly obvious that we've got a
beautiful counter lever over there come
back to our window our pallet AI
visualizer let's get rid of our Timber
feature glass and concrete only and
let's also get rid of our Christmas
lights in this instance we'll go large
can to lever with curved glass elements
hit that generate button and let's see
what inspiration we can get oh Jesus
okay once again it's gone way off base
designed a fullstory architectural home
with a large can to L fantastic but it
hasn't used any of the actual shapes
that we provided that's probably because
our shape Fidelity is too low we'd have
to increase that to 100 % and try once
again definitely more on theme with this
image with what we're trying to actually
articulate it looks like a bunch of
shipping containers stacked together
with a bit of glass in them but overall
it's put it in a meadow it's put some
beautiful Hills behind it it looks
actually quite nice from a general
render perspective the architecture is
horrible but it's done a decent job and
that's the overall theme of this Arad AI
visualizer it's there to help inspire
you in your ideas and your designs but
definitely not to actually inform the
design itself it's getting better every
single day that we try and use this
system and it's definitely improving
every single week so maybe in a few more
years we might have some serious
improvements in this technology but for
now nothing to be afraid of nothing to
worry about except a great resource for
some incredible inspiration anyway
that's all from me team my name's David
Tomic and if you enjoyed the video
consider subscribing for more weekly
content